buenos días el juicio político al
presidente de martín vizcarra se inicia
a las 9 de la mañana para esta hora ha
sido programada la sesión en la que se
ha citado a los legisladores se tiene
previsto que el mandatario ejerza su
defensa a partir de las 10 en punto y
tendrá una hora para hacerlo
posteriormente a esto se iniciará un
debate en el cual los legisladores
tendrán una duración de unas cuantas
horas para debatir y esto podría durar
unas cuantas horas como he señalado
extenderse a lo largo de la noche
posteriormente ellos votarán y decidirán
si martín vizcarra continúa siendo
presidente o le declara la vacancia
presidencial hay que señalar que el
mandatario de acuerdo a la constitución
no está obligado a asistir al
impeachment y el el tampoco ha dado a
conocer su intención de hacerlo es por
eso que todas las miradas están
centradas en su abogado roberto pereira
francisco cuáles son los argumentos de
su defensa la defensa del presidente
el autor roberto pereyra ha señalado que
su defensa se centrará en que no existen
causas suficientes para declarar la
vacancia presidencial por incapacidad
moral él ha advertido que la
constitución peruana no establece que
los audios puedan ser elementos
suficientes jurídicamente para destituir
al mandatario y vamos a ver cómo le va
al presidente oa su abogado en esta
sesión en el parlamento peruano
francisco gracias por información que
tenga usted un feliz resto del día por
supuesto muy pendientes de lo que ocurra
en lima la capital peruana sobre el
futuro del presidente de vizcarra